kala how do your socks get holes the
size of all your toes
oh honey let me tell you i don't i've
never lived life hard enough
to like have the whole sock be open at
the foot well
i think it's a commitment to not getting
rid of them i'm
i can't have nice things same thing the
bottom line first of all same
aggressive same because but i have a
reason but how can i get more compelling
than yours
why do you guys get to be friends with
me such a nice thing
what's your reason um i have six animals
and i fostered too many animals and
um they are not all on the same
intelligence level and they
some like to rip socks apart oh those
are dog tears those are those aren't
like puppies esther was looking at it
like you'd been like out running in
gravel
but but i do think i do think we should
normalize
mismatched socks that's going to make it
to your wiki feet that toe
it out pixelate it i'm on the annie
agenda
i what do you guys think like do you do
you think that
adults like there's always this pressure
i feel like where people shame you when
you're so
they always point it out when my socks
aren't matching i'm like who [ __ ]
matches socks yeah it's a very punky
brewster
it's cuter to have your socks not match
i'm almost like jealous of that i'm
i lose so many socks and i've just i've
tried to stay committed to the matching
socks lifestyle but maybe i should just
abandon
i have some questions please now
laundry how does it get done at your
house i am a laundry
lover i love doing laundry i do it all
um i do mine i do his i do
donuts i believe this because i've never
been on face time with you without your
hands moving
in a folding manner you're always
folding
and dave likes his laundry hung up but i
don't care i fold them we have this
conversation every week
i wish you'd hang it i i'm sorry these
are the coved protocols and kobe we're
just folding water
what do you think do you fold underwear
i filled everything i love folding do
you fold it like marie kondo
no no i i no but one time brenda's song
i i was at her house and i left a shirt
there and the next day she brought it to
work
and it was folded like a little like
sandwich it was like a swan
yeah it was so special and then i like
spent all this time trying to learn how
to fold and
i just my folding is not good have you
ever um this could be maybe
next year's birthday present have you
ever gotten one of those folders
the those are the boards amateurs
it never is the right size i don't i
don't like the board telling me what
size my
i know and also you don't know the
length of the shelf um
i am a professional and i mean
professional masterful
um air folder no one can fold or air
fold t-shirts
are you one of the people that does the
pinch and then can like you know
a flip and a down can we get a shirt
is there nothing i should show you
pictures i should send you pictures of
my well
annie you've seen me annie take your
shirt off someone's a viewer just ask
yes give me give me somebody's t-shirt
oh my god
no bra again i've never i don't own a
bra are we really gonna do this
you're not my friend here i'm gonna say
something i did consider us friends
until this
it's it's incessant she's saying this
thing i've never had a bra i've known
you for 12 years i've never had a bra
i've never owned a bra why they don't
fit me
they don't come in small tit fat back
that's our size okay
[Music]
there's no it's like it's too wide
there's no they're far
set what about when you work out i mean
i have sports bras but
they're really just you know to their
nipple covers so it doesn't bother you
to be brawless you don't feel you have
nipple issues
hey i have nipple issues too sensitive
well no mine i just think they're mine
tears off i have puffy nipples what
oh you have like emotional issues with
your nipples
oh i don't like when you do that i think
this actually hurts esther it's this is
a meena you guys say i'm mean to esther
this
is the meanest thing i've ever you have
to i'm just can't look do you just look
another year
though you know what when she ravishes
her own nipples like
you sound horny though
[Laughter]
um i mean if she she looks like she's in
control
she's in control wait can i try
something what
what the [ __ ] is that this is gonna this
is a pixel episode because i did already
show my tits
but i i had my nipples pierced when i
was 14 to when i was 20. no
no you're no i'm gonna i'm gonna see if
they still go through
okay they're still nipple chews i'm
gonna esther just look away i want some
nipples what's your little drink i'm
gonna enjoy my drink is that an rc cold
why do you match your drink she's
wearing a shirt that matches the drink
it's my new sponsor it actually might be
you never know with esther
i pay them but it's a deal
one day esther's going to make a dollar
i swear annie careful
do not slow down can i like i'm not
looking forward
bryce nobody cares if you see them it's
fine they're very unaffected no one
respects you either price
it's not that it's just that's not going
to change your life it will not change
your day
do you want um some lotion or lube
why would that help okay boobs out oh my
god annie you have perfect nipples thank
you they're about to get
poked okay i need to these are like from
i'm like shaking there's like a my spine
is
okay oh my god kyla you're watching
of course i can't pee on my eyes do you
think a nurse is allowed to be like
upset with nipples
oh my gosh enough to go through it's not
really long enough to go through well
it's pierced in i just don't know
[Laughter]
you guys look you can see it hanging
below honestly they look like
should i try the other one majestic
majestic look
i do think that that might is this
cultural appropriation
there's got to be some tribe somewhere
that does this oh my god
wait well you have both nipples pierced
i had them well one was piercing 14
moments pierced at 16.
okay let's go let's go oh so there's
just like a hole in your nose
at all times okay it's going in
it's going down
i'm not forcing i'm just sort of like
trying to find the path okay
why is this happening is there cheese is
there cheese
yeah there's definitely can you i have
to this is the anti-esther's birthday
can we
please talk about that this is the
opposite of estrogen can you please
start a conversation with me
i'm transfixed i would like i can do
nothing else but stare
directly into oh my god she got it in
the second one is in eddie i have to
take a picture i'm so sorry
this is what cluster addicts have led me
to
does it feel what does it feel like
annie it doesn't really feel like
anything this has to go into our only
fan
it would be a shame if it didn't ew do
you want to smell the
yeah what you're gonna smell it yeah i
love cheese
you have it in your ears your nasty
pierced ears that's so
different and it's the same smell that's
like
sexual what you guys are doing it's a
sex act
don't you do you smell the cheese oh
it's good
it's really juicy yeah yeah the white
stuff still comes out
grace is like having a whole experience
oh annie that's good
and this was the day george took to take
off wow what's wrong with you that you
like that
look at her she looks bobby she's in
love with your
male counterpart who do you think i feel
like
esther and i are both like bobby and
esther and i are so
different yeah like together you make
one bobby lee we make one bobby
you're two opposite parts of him that's
why you like us
yeah it's true and that's why i'm very
comfortable with you guys because i'm
like well
this feels familiar i was comfortable
with you guys
until i just saw you smell her nipple
cheese like that
is just do you smell your own cheese do
you smell your own floss
when you floss no i don't smell my face
she doesn't have to
how do you know how do you know if it's
a good day or a bad day
i want to go home today can i be excused
i'm like
50 serious can we just talk about
something else you've made me so
uncomfortable
i i actually am do we have an hr
department
on this show imagine this never would
have happened
do we need to do an early banana break
call the banana breakouts or if it's
if it's caused you trauma i need a
banana break okay let's go banana bread
early banana i actually really need it
like seriously thank you for that
oh but they're not even organic
potassium oh my god i knew this day
would come
i knew it give it to her yeah yeah yeah
the prince is upset wait don't annie i
know how you can make this up to me oh
my god the fact that this isn't
okay so what is this so it's ocean it's
blue
flavored maple syrup it looks like
laundry detergent
okay i this isn't on the list of cluster
heading triggers but i have a feeling
me thinks me might be getting a cluster
headache from this
i can't believe they found that in a
grocery store it's just it's
can i see the lady wait this actually
makes aunt jemima being taken off
[ __ ] up there should be no one on
these cap and
crunch ocean blue artificially maple
flavored syrup mapiel and annie if you
i recently did a post on instagram about
this i said i would love for someone to
watch this
i would love to watch someone drink this
it would make me high
and i just want to know if you want to
make make me high
so from nipple shoes to this that could
rely when you're back i could clean the
slate
okay so the reason this is near and dear
to my heart what i'm about to do is
when i was a kid i used to come home my
dad would be chugging ancho mama's like
this is angelima by the way yeah they
[ __ ] replaced aunt jemima with a
white guy
no i think that's just cap'n crunch
that's just an addition all right i
don't know what it is if we don't get
sponsored by these people i
am quitting broadcasting okay well then
i guess this is our last day
all right so my dad when i used to come
downstairs
um in the morning my dad would be
getting ready for work and he would be
chugging into my house i swear to god i
thought that's how you ate syrup
when we would go to ihop i thought like
you can order a cup of syrup
like i thought it was a beverage why was
he doing that
because he's a fat piggy i don't know
also anchovies isn't even real syrup
that was they tricked us our whole lives
it's not even real maple syrup it's a
flavored
sauce how does it taste danny like
exactly like angelima's
squeeze it out oh my god the blue oh my
god
more
oh my god
look at me what does it taste like
monster
um it tastes a lot like monster energy
drink
no it tastes like um exactly like ant
chamas
it doesn't taste any different probably
just with um food coloring with an
illegal amount of food coloring
i've never seen anything so blue it's
beautiful you're gonna have green poo
later
no way because you remember those um
those candies
the those balls that would cause like a
color explosion in your mouth
no those balls most candy i think you
were assaulted
how many times is one person molested
but i'd always cry because they're like
mom
my poo is green it should be like would
you eat and it was always that the food
coloring
i think the blue is off okay will you
tell us later if your poo is green
i will i mean that's what brought us
together to begin with was my black poop
it's true okay kalila yesterday i was
driving
i was actually on the phone with with
bryce
and george our podcast producers because
i was begging them
to help me with glowing up my other
feelings oh my god wait that's
really sad just wait i hope they said no
i had been begging
i'll walk out if they said yes i've been
begging them to do a phone call with me
right so like finally they may give me
the time of day to do a phone call
and bryce is like mid explaining
something i'm like i have to go
i'm so sorry i have to go there's a dog
on the street and i
i like i locked eyes with this dog and
i'm like i just i everything in my
everything else has gone away and i hung
up i pulled over
this little white like fluffy terrier
ish thing and i i was like i have to
rescue this dog
wait can i just i want to just unpack
what you said already okay
you begged them for a phone call and
immediately got off the phone call
that's that was exactly for this exactly
so i was like [ __ ]
but so i walk towards it
it's it's really not interested it's so
mangy and
it was pooping while walking oh no
what is that about oh no was it a puppy
or a full-grown
a full-grown dog i mean it could be
anything it could be anything from
this temper parvo worms digestive issues
ate something bad food poisoning who
knows
maybe it's just like good with time like
listen no
i got [ __ ] to do so it was that dog and
then another dog came out a little
beagle
and i was walking around just trying to
like here you know looking for food in
my car i had nothing which now i know
that's very surprising there wasn't any
there were no crumbs it was dave's car
okay so then i see this guy who's like
also pulled over and i'm like hey like
are these your dogs he's like no he's
like but i've been working on a house
around here and i
they've been here like every day and i'm
like okay
so i guess these are just like street
dogs that live here right off a freeway
exit and it just freaked me out
i couldn't get them so i called a couple
people
i forgot that you're also like a dog
yeah i have all the things in my car to
capture a dog
so i called whitney i called miranda i
called carlos
and i talked to a few rescues i don't
want to say one of these people has to
not be famous
i can't hear you talk all the famous
people you called oh carlos okay good
it's famous people are the only people
have time for this [ __ ] or carlos
so i don't know if anyone was able to
get them
but i it just was a really it was
difficult i don't know what you and
but one of my friends said that she'll
go with me this weekend to see if we can
find them again but like what do you do
is that have you been through that
yeah what do you you just snatch them up
you get them you get
take them to the vet to get them you
could have gotten them no i swear
it is do you think they saw you and were
like oh my god is she okay
she's oh look at how she's diaper
walking
poor things just see if they're chipped
if they have an owner if not
the you don't want to put them in the
shelter so see if
someone will foster them so they never
have to step foot in a shelter now when
you say mangy do you mean
physically because you know my dog had
mange were they missing
they just were like overgrown hair
matted dirt yeah matted dirty
they definitely look like they've been
on the street for a while i know it's
you should get them on glowing up would
you
blowing up my beauty podcast subscribe
um yeah it was really difficult and i
was just curious like
what do you do when you see that and
like i don't know my friend told me it
was probably for the best that i didn't
catch them because it would have been
like a whole thing but i don't know i
just
especially because it was dave's car
imagine you see a cute dog like
that i can't i'm just from not from here
so that is crazy to me that they're just
dogs on the street i don't that's tricky
any anywhere in l.a
i'm always so freaked out because of
like fast traffic yeah so when i see a
dog i always panic
start stopping cars yeah it is i'm like
there was one time in the 101 freeway
one-on-one style we were on our way to
irvine improv um for his show he was
already running late
and um there was a [ __ ] husky
and i i i was so dumb i there was me and
one other guy in a motorcycle but we
were running
on a freeway in tandem side by side and
bobby's just following me like are you
[ __ ] crazy and um
thankfully um the husky exited and then
someone was able to catch was bobby late
to a show and needed to get on the back
of the motorcycle
um is there any way we can zoom down and
look at how little esther is this is the
cutest
if people have no clue how little you
are they really don't they just think
i'm a monster
look at that esther's legs by the way
look at the hair it's for you what she
makes up in her height she
gets in the length of hers no people
will always tell me i'm pasty but if you
have the leg hair it kind of
looks like the illusion of a tan she's
wearing like
they're infant shoes the shoes of an
infant um
she her feet don't touch the ground
is it okay that i'm using this as a foot
rest yeah it's bobby's dad's ashes
[Laughter]
but even if they were it's fine have you
guys ever been catfished
no of you yeah what yeah i thought that
was just a myspace thing everyone got
catfished
right how do you have my story what is
your story remember when i got
gang cyber raped oh wait
by a catfish i was catfished i want to
know
no tell your story i'll tell my next oh
mine is just it was what i thought was
like a really hot australian boy but he
turned out to be
um um a very scrawny
um old indian man my name is esther
[Laughter]
i do feel like i would be the catfisher
like nobody's catfish i'm the catfisher
i feel like
what would you whose picture would you
use
but this guy was like had kids he made
oh my god i still remember his my space
handle was a murcito 888
and i was so just like mesmerized did
you hit him up or he came to you
well my friend [ __ ] me over she was
like he was uh
who my friend lived in australia and she
was like oh yeah i know this guy
so i was like oh then he's a real guy
and we like had this long distance thing
for so long he sent me like
care packages all of these things and i
was so in love we were going to meet up
in the philippines at some point
and i got a little suspicious one time
because he called me and i heard like
babies crying in the back
and i was like where are you did he have
an australian accent he did
he did but also all the songs that he
loved were
old 70s early 80s songs like
caribbean queen which i love is a great
song great [ __ ] song
yeah but he was like oh this is like my
most favorite song i was like that's
weird for someone in their 20s like i
like that song too but
like you know yeah my dad was 97 when i
was born
yeah and he would always i'm like what
are you eating he's like oh i'm eating
nasi goreng and i'm like oh okay that's
i like that
you're a white guy who's like into
indonesian food or other cultures
but it turns out he was a family man and
he was a guy in like his 60s
how long did that go for and i asked my
friend i was like so what's he like in
person she's like oh i've never met him
oh my god couldn't you have [ __ ] told
me that you guys were like homies for
real
so what you thought this was like a
hawkeye you were gonna meet yeah
we didn't know any better at you know
during the myspace years right
all i cared about was like my top 16 and
like rearranging depending whose
attitude was bad when did we get a top
oh my god top 16 came after like right
before
um um facebook exodus because i remember
it was friendster first
friendster service first were you too
young for friendster yeah i didn't have
friendster
did you have um zanga no i had myspace
though
okay do you remember your myspace songs
yeah i do pretty proud of them tell me
it was lady gaga paparazzi like before
that album had even come out
i feel like myspace was so lame by the
time no
it was i was really early with it you
just gotta trust me
that was really early there's something
so untrustworthy about you
i only trust people whose feet touch the
ground i don't
you guys let's talk about better help
we're all obsessed with it we all need
it i want to call it best help honestly
because it's
better than most help it's the best
annie what interferes with your
happiness
besides me i'm glad that you're starting
to learn that because
i thought i was gonna have to change but
it turns out you're learning and growing
well just so you know better help can
assist you and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist
and it can connect you in a safe and
private online environment and it's so
convenient
you can start communicating with a
therapist in under 48 hours
they also have a journal feature which i
love the most and
it's basically where um leading up to
your appointment you can write down your
daily thoughts your concerns your
worries things that are
you know getting in the way of your life
and that now your therapist has
access to so by the time you do um have
a sit down or one hour video chat or
phone chat with her
um she now you don't need to start from
scratch she will have already known what
was happening
in your week leading up to that point
write a poem about your pain
you can send a message to your counselor
anytime you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid
is available and this service is
available for clients worldwide you can
find the
particular expertise that you need
online so don't limit yourself to the
the counselors that are just located
near you there are licensed professional
counselors who specialize in anger
depression stress anxiety relationship
sleeping trauma grief self-esteem
anything you share is
of course confidential it's convenient
professional and affordable
and so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
why did you read my list of things that
are wrong with me esther
no reason what i can help with no reason
but pretty much annie
very rude for you to say all of those at
once you guys we want you to start
living a happier life today
annie as a listener you'll get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at betterhelp.com
bloodbath join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help
h-e-l-p dot com slash bloodbath
what was your myspace song um i switched
my song from
one shaq song to another song and
someone was like did you just change
your song from one shack song to another
song and i was like yes i did
and i used to have i do believe i peaked
on myspace i used to have um
i would like have the background be like
dolphins like
jumping into diamonds oh that's cool i
really enjoyed it i really enjoyed my
mine was very um top eight was so fun
yeah
top eight and i didn't like know anyone
else on myspace i feel like you guys
really lived a life on
oh yeah my space was the best my space i
think we should all go back to my space
there was something more wholesome about
it it was more like
i don't know it reminded me kind of of
like it was like bright light it was fun
i don't know
and you could personalize your page and
then you can actually you had like i
remember
writing so much poetry on there on my um
blogs
my blogs would get me so cancelled i'm
just remembering someone like oh god
why what did they say you know i was you
know it was my opportunity to make like
abortion jokes and stuff
you know we were so different in that
regard my blogs would be like poems one
of my poems was
like owed to the baby the pigeons walked
me home it was just so
emo i was a really emo writer so emo
i was so that person for a long time um
so pigeons walked you home pigeons
walked me out but it was just like a
that was a great poem i wrote are we
just two pigeons in the
in the life of kalila i have a thing for
pigeons you guys
pigeony pigeons rats and cockroaches i
have a thing for
we're pigeons with fake eyelashes okay
you know what
last a few weeks ago we did an episode
with bobby and
she said esther if i was into [ __ ]
she would be into me and i got really
like you know excited like oh and then i
realized who her [ __ ] boyfriend is
yeah it's not a compliment it's actually
like oh big [ __ ] deal
yeah you would be an upgrade and now
you're telling us you like cockroaches
no no i respect them because any any
think about it oh my god
they can walk headless for 20 days or
something like that but anything that
competes with humans or who are very
very like resilient
and we consider pests but if you think
about it they're just geniuses that are
able to live
side by side with us so pigeons safer
they have better navigation than gps
rats they're very cute with their family
they're industrious um cockroaches they
don't [ __ ] die
and they'll be here when this world is
over they've lived for like
the whole every single era of time i
mean that's cool
i still don't care for them i don't like
cockroaches i i
like literally have a actual fear for
them i just respect them mutual respect
mutual respect they say back up don't
come near me
and we should bow down yeah bow down
what do you what would you do if you saw
one though like in your
i would scream yeah i i love spiders
love all insane
like i respect you but i
and when you kill them what ha something
will come out of them no
oh you guys i think it's like their
babies
can be that's a spider spider's
egg sack right what do you mean
if you like hit a spider thing on a sack
no no if there's an ester show us how
you hit this bite out of a sack
if you hit a spider sack all the babies
come out and explode
oh but the spider like why is that what
your doctor told you as a kid
because maybe join the molested by a
doctor club
the baby's splooged out because there's
some with some spiders inspiring
the spiderlings they they ride on the
mother's back for weeks because spider
moms are the best moms
it's like where's the spider dad nowhere
to be found he's doing [ __ ] nothing
but in the insect world the woman is
usually bigger stronger and eats the
male so
all is fair yeah why don't we have that
for humans
would you just decapitate dave after you
have sex with him
is that an option if that was my genetic
code
yeah you wouldn't be laughing we'd be
imagine she just takes a chunk out of
his cheek
[Laughter]
oh i had rat i had pet rats when i was a
kid i'm so jealous paris hilton had a
pet rat
i read that in her book and she also had
a need to join
you're just such a celebrity like
stick sucker you just love the
celebrities
i l i worship most celebrities from like
my
teen years but i'm not like you're like
a poster girl like you had like posters
everywhere i absolutely did who did you
have posters up of britney
christina aguilera um i actually
remember the first time i got really bad
period cramps when i was like 13.
i had all these like magazine cutouts on
my wall and i was so
angry and angsty from the pain i was
feeling i couldn't believe it i ripped
down all the guys
and after that were the guys on the wall
it was probably like in sync
and stuff like that taylor thomas no i
wasn't into him
i know he wasn't my type no just
probably in sync and
whatever leo leonardo
but i ripped all the guys off because i
was like they don't know what to do what
leo was your favorite leo
titanic how could you even ask oh i
thought you're gonna say gilbert grape
um i liked him no because my favorite
was romeo and juliet
uh that was kind of my only because i
never stand him because he
like looks like very feminine and young
i wrote him extreme fan mail
not just fan mail right because i was
living in the philippines at this time i
would drive flowers for him
and i would press them for a week i
would go through all the and then i
would um
save up all my lunch money because
postage was really expensive to send to
america
and i would write i would read i would
write um lines from titanic
like there's only 10 cents in my pocket
you know that thing he says to
to um to kate and um yeah i
to this day no response not a poster
not a sign nothing oh listen we know one
of his friends
we do whose like credit is that he's
friends with leonardo
gabriel you know that's true yeah it
used to be michael ravenborg but then
michael rappelford started performing
and so now we all know him but like
he's like yeah i know leo like he's so
open about that
being his main thing i'm just shocked
that you like took all this time and
energy and money to like send
things to a movie star like what did you
what were you wanting
you just needed to like see her and then
he would know i think i didn't want
anything besides just him to know what
an impact he made
like i was obsessed you guys i cried
every night i watched titanic
maybe 65 times at that age it's an
incredible film
incredible yeah i saw it about four
weeks when my heart will go on comes on
i still cry
it's a really yeah that movie was hot as
[ __ ]
bobby's never seen it what happened how
are these people that haven't seen
titanic i'm just kidding i've seen it a
lot of times i was joking
okay good that was bobby's never seen it
he says here i like that he
hasn't good for you bobby don't [ __ ]
see it so many
oscars my god ten that year cause i mean
they were like kate winslet's fat and
then like if you look at her now she's
like so much skinnier than all of us
all they talked about was how fat she
was they did this person
who yes all the magazines were like
about her weight gain
it was brutal back in the day oh god it
was
brutal wasn't that crazy though when you
did you guys watch framing britney a few
weeks ago like
all the interviewers are like so tell us
about your breasts
it's just like what she's 17 like what
the weight then you were like also like
but
but like the thing is that the way they
treated people and also did you guys see
kim kardashian posted like
how she was treated and it was all these
magazine covers about
her being really fat and being like the
pig is back at it
oh my god when she was pregnant there
were these vile
things and that was like not that long
ago
i say we should keep doing it let's just
go and harder who cares
thick skin you want to know why i'm fat
because i got thick skin
call me fat [ __ ] piggy kim is crying
in the gutter like it was
left high and dry it was terrible
whatever
you fat [ __ ]
she was talking to you kim oh my god
you're never going to get skims for full
price anymore
esther would you be willing someday i
know that you and i don't do
um las vegas but would
one day would in a safe environment
would you be willing to do ayahuasca
with me
i don't know no okay why you're not
willing to open portals
i don't understand what it is i don't
know why everyone i don't get it i'm too
afraid
have you done it no never have you yeah
are you kidding you stupid [ __ ] she has
a shaman she calls her shopping
after my i'm like i was thinking about
you my i'm you're never popping into my
head during a trip again i
i remember where i was when i was
talking about it and you're like well i
don't know
the diff like i don't remember that was
ayahuasca i remember that but that could
to me it's all the same
mushrooms ls mustard mushrooms what are
these
mushrooms must tries i'll tell you that
wait you're dmt queen she's a dmt queen
what is
is like the ultimate though i would say
ayahuasca is like the most like
like impactful amazing beautiful
experience it's like insane it's like 30
years of therapy but dmt and ayahuasca
are the same
chemical that's released from your brain
but ayahuasca has
um like it's uh like inhibits it so it's
like it
goes longer so when you smoke dmt it's
um like five to ten minutes and then
when you do ios it's like six hours
does it have that thing where they say
when you do certain drugs like
you feel good and then you get real low
after
does it have that i love that you're
going off like an article you read in ym
magazine
do you guys know the term spinner yeah
oh i just learned that
it's a tiny person you spin on top of
your dick it's what guy
is what men call girls like me
she's a spinner we are not spinners we
are unspinnable annie
i am also unspinnable just to be clear
no no annie and i are because of like
the
drying the like suction the dry
creaminess
of the creamy the sort of muddiness okay
i annie and i we're just just to be
smashed we were not to be spinned
i'm like you're supposed to like be mad
at me and shoving my face into something
oh my god it's true what i mean or i'm
telling jokes what do you want
do you want a laffy [ __ ] or do you want
to shut me down
hannie what was your i know you told me
once that you went on an all-girls
ayahuasca trip
i thought it was ayahuasca okay so wait
you went on an all-girls trip without me
yes this is a problem yes i did i went
on an all-girls trip
no little boys allowed who were the
girls can i know
are they the girls i know yeah they are
girls you know
is it that true yeah okay but it's not
the one that i want to write a horror
movie about okay
these [ __ ] [ __ ] this was the
precursor to like a like a hellish mean
girl weekend i was on
but okay so it was a friend of mine this
comedian i used to be friends with
and her manager was a female manager
which i always thought
that would be cool to have a female
manager until this experience
why do you call the manager a female
manager that seems kind of sexist
what would you want me to say instead
girl manager manager
just a me i'm not a girl i don't know
about you i'm just an actor well it's an
all woman's things i have to explain
are you an actor i've seen your work
you're just the person that keeps
looking at camera
so her her manager had like gone
had worked with these people these
shamans okay
and it was so she was like oh i want to
get a group of us together
she was like some female comedians and
this and the manager
and me and so we paid 350
to spend the night at these people's
house so i thought we were gonna go do
ayahuasca like
in like some beautiful place we drive to
um near the airport it's like
oh okay so we drive towards the airport
we go to these people's house it's just
like this rich couple with like tons of
like botox and stuff and i'm like
if you like if the medicine works
wouldn't you not have botox like
wouldn't you like not
fall into that world you know what i
mean but i'm like all right i'm gonna
i'm gonna suspend my judgment i'm gonna
just keep doing this you know this
girl's manager was loved these people
and swore by them
so we get there we bring our own
sleeping bags we bring our own breakfast
350. what am i paying for um what did
you bring for breakfast who knows
probably funyuns i always bring bunions
um so we get there
and then what they end up giving us it's
not ayahuasca it's sassafras which i
think you can just get
it's like a heart opener it's a it's
like a light version
of molly pretty much so
this woman's like leading the ceremony
we go around we say our intentions or
whatever they give us this drug that's
like
okay but it's not like 350
worth of okay and we're hanging out it's
like kind of fun and we're like talking
and everything
and then uh the woman you know a lot of
us had issues with men
and the woman's like all right well i'm
gonna now bring my husband down
a bunch of girls on molly okay
girls on molly in their pajamas all
girls we're all [ __ ] up
i'm gonna bring my husband down he is
the divine masculine so he'll help you
cure your man problems so then this guy
with bro talks is like old man who like
i'm not going to say he's a child
monster because i don't think he was a
child monster but if you were to
take a pen and pa paper and go like i'm
going to draw what
someone that molest children looks like
this was the man
okay he was like his jeans were very
tight
he was like you know in his like maybe
late 60s
gray hair skin so taut and smooth
just so tight um i want nothing to do
this guy but i'm like ugh whatever so
she brings him to me so we're sitting
there i'm all [ __ ] up right
i'm like okay she's like uh
starting to explain to me she's like
well sometimes when we do ceremony we
and he starts interrupting her and
speaking for her
and i go i'm sorry dude this is like her
thing what the [ __ ]
why are you interrupting her and like
speaking for her right
and then everyone's like gets like
really tense like oh we weren't
expecting any sort of like pushback on
any of this right
so i'm going like i just woman marched i
wore the [ __ ] hat
now we got this [ __ ] i'm here with
all these women like
i'm trying to become a lesbian i'm
trying to i'm hope it's a choice
like i would like to never see a man
again and then this guy's like
interrupting his wife it's already
creepy
he's there like why is he here with all
of us she ends up being like no no he's
good i'm like all right whatever
so then i was like all right we'll do
your like mail curing
thing i will no longer be upset with men
i'm in my most man-haity phase so what
he does is
i lay down okay on my side
he lays behind me as the big spoon he
wraps his arms and legs around me and
then whispers in my ear and goes
and i'm like like there's got to be a
boner here like i just was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
so he does that for like 15 minutes i'm
like all right dude you got to go and
then i'm just like i don't know what
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is like what the [ __ ]
is this guy
what is happening of course the girl's
manager is like andy you're like these
are my p like so everyone's like mad at
me and i'm like there's no way this is
acceptable
i'm on molly this guy just came down is
rubbing his [ __ ] old man boner my
[ __ ]
like making moaning noises in my ear to
protect me from what men have done
who is this i don't know what this guy
does this is your husband
so then the rest of the night is her
like she's like you have a real issue
with men like you really
i'm like what the [ __ ] well i'm being
gaslit at this thing
and um but it ended up like so i was the
one that first said something right but
then all the other girls like
after the weekend it started to kind of
come out where they're like yeah he like
came down and laid on top of me and
kissed me on the floor
i'm like we don't want this so i think
like i don't know if people went back to
them
but i know they ended up having like a
very awkward car ride
oh yeah with the two like they came to
so he was meant to be
the divine masculine that was supposed
to yeah you don't who
the [ __ ] you don't get to decide to me
that you're that i never met you dude
that's just weird that's like how nexium
starts
yes it felt very necessary yeah that's
scary
that's the beginnings of you're gonna
yeah that's because can i show you how
many times
everyone's always mad at me and i'm the
[ __ ] only one saying the thing i'm
like
first of all why the [ __ ] did he just
interrupt you why is he here
what why are we all [ __ ] up in pajamas
like i'm in like silk pajamas right now
like why is this man
spooning me yeah so then
um everyone i guess was mad at me about
that secretly and then i went on a girls
trip
i've never been treated i really do
respect you for seeking out these like
new experiences though because i'm such
you cannot sell me on anything like it
you can't even sell me on drugs really
like i'm just now
maybe considering mushrooms but it's
just
i don't i'm so freaked out by being
around like
new people in that way i'm just so
untrustworthy right
like no why do you respect it i i don't
i'm like
why did you do that look at what
happened because it couldn't rub your
nose in it
50 50 it could have been a great
experience if the if divine masculine
didn't walk down the stairs it could
have just been a sassafras with girls
time
we can do that the three of us we can go
to a house together the three of us in
palm springs and
and do sassafras no we wait make s'mores
and
swim toes a four-year-old
we're with a girl who has not grown
since age four
physically or emotionally she missed one
of the eriksen stages
she's like oh why would she do that that
doesn't sound fun
i'll show you a sober good time don't
use your little
predator hands people is that you
getting in both of us at once
people love to travel and spend time
with me because
you'll be surprised people have to
travel with you i would like to you to
call one person that's enjoyed traveling
with you
caroline well caroline's a very
easygoing person
with everyone bobby proposed something
he says that he will
you know still know still no it's a no
he proposed that he said that he would
buy all of our plane tickets if we all
fully whenever all of us filmed all of
us ourselves in the philippines for
two weeks oh done oh no but that's not a
deal
who says no to this it's so amazing
they're esther
he's done do it first of all what's a
philippines ticket what 30
two weeks though is really great for me
i'm someone i want to go to paris
well the flight is four days you know
that right no and that's not it is two
days
i first of all be very fun to travel
with you too so i actually would do it
two weeks scares me with anything
okay i got it but a week i think we
could
we could do that she's gonna be
someone's mother one day do you
understand
i am donut's mother that's who i was
born to be
funny enough if donna could talk i have
a feeling you would love it there
what would it be like tell me what would
we do it's just
the best it's it's a tropical rainforest
with the best beaches the friendliest
people everyone's disgusted by
everything
i like pretty beaches i love to be in
like cozy clothes at the beach
yes we can do that well we can do we can
we can wear ambrose
what kind of food we need to get do you
have one of those very organic head
that kids have no wait why don't we
we got her one of those you know like
the kids have like that corner
that they put on the towels where it's
got like the corner that they put on
their head and
wrap around oh yeah i've always asked
her yes
do you have footy pajamas i do of course
oh
those are hard though i don't like
zipping the top off when you have to go
peepee or poo poo yeah they don't really
have like place for brown skins for
small small
they are hard for boobs yeah until the
year
so you've been with dave so long that
you never got a chance to do any swipe
left
swipe right that was not really terrible
it seems like it's not
it seems like it's not good for
everybody you really
dodged a bullet you really did i guess i
did
yeah once you get in you're never
allowed back why
if i [ __ ] someone i met off the internet
i'm never
they're never going to be in my life
again why is it one and done then yeah
oh what if you're feeling it there's no
way i would be feeling it i bet
i met bobby i've never met a person i
liked on the internet i met bobby on
on tinder yeah but bobby's famous
not that you're going off of him being
famous but i'm just saying like you know
his personality like you've seen him
like
i'm going off of literally like a square
picture of someone i have no clue what
they smell like
i have no clue what they act like i have
no clue anything about them
and i met two guys on dating sites and
it was always like right after a breakup
i never was like really single during
the boom of internet dating
so i didn't realize that you aren't
supposed to be like hey i'm gonna [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of you to a complete
stranger you've never met
so then i would be like let's bang and
then i'd meet up with these people like
oh god i'm like not attracted to you at
all and then i have to bang you because
i've already
are you serious yeah twice that happened
you were not into them and you had sex
with them
yeah can you walk us through that
well because back in the day okay back
in the
day before i had my self-confidence that
i got about it one year ago
i when the world i always felt like i
wanted to make i wanted to make
i i was more worried about making other
people happy than myself
so i was so i felt so uncomfortable
rejecting these people to their face
especially when i'd come so hard at them
on the internet like it's not like they
were like
come [ __ ] me [ __ ] like i was like glaze
me like a donut like i mean i literally
was like going in so hard you said you
talk like that i am gonna slap
both cheeks and i'm talking about the
bottom ones
i'm going to spank you a little boy i
didn't know you talk like that
yes you do i know how you talk one of
your exes told me but i won't
reveal it what i want to know
what is this inappropes but i want to
know what
how you talk i know i want to know what
i just you're a filthy pig
i just want people to know she's a fil
this is an all an act a monster
i'm i wouldn't okay maybe i'm filthy but
glaze me like a doughnut that's like it
sounds like are you jealous
it's like art food yeah i knew you were
impressed it's poetic
lays me like a donut ice we're gonna ice
bucket challenger just
i had some good ones real sign of the
times i was always jealous of people
that could go on raya
which people don't know raya is supposed
to be like the
artistic like celebrity the worst one
but then number one the worst one it's
then but then i realized from everyone
who has it it's like
all 19 year old instagram models
and then gross old old men
wait you know what it is you were on
youtube yeah this is the issue with raya
raya is oh i went on a date with a guy
from ryan that was
i didn't have sex with um wait wait wait
wait wait
um let me guess is it his choice is
you're saying his choice
obviously and everyone that's asked um
yeah that was the singer-songwriter guy
but uh boy was he weird
i just i'm so glad it didn't work out
because i would have had to explain a
lot of hats to people
i screamed when you told me who it was
oh i started singing his song to you
remember and you're like this is
triggering
can you stop do i know sometimes those
songs come on
uh maybe maybe she's else i'll sing it
acts like i don't talk to her every day
like
you of course you know i you have
blocked out
no i don't remember can i just tell you
that we're getting to the bottom of this
friendship
and by the bottom the end of it you have
so many stories
i don't they all sort of blend together
i'll see if i will say this
i will give esther this it doesn't
matter if she's listening really i am
just talking do you know what i mean
i've never really
called i've never really been like can
you repeat what i said
i've just been like there's a face i
tend to be
attracted to people who like to talk i
love talkers i love people
where i can just sit back take all the
information and i need
use it against them when i need to
that's not me but be entertained and
like
i you're entertaining so i like to just
oh like a
like a king you're a boy like you're the
king no
no it's like you're the star i just flip
on the show and you're there you are
again when you do this i don't
understand what the you're a voyer
and she's an exhibition yeah you are i'm
a voyer yeah can i sing you the song we
can bleep this out
i'm so embarrassed it's going to trigger
annie right now
so yeah that's what helen hold on
no so i that's why i don't know who it
is because i never knew
wait but wasn't he a quaker also are you
willing to talk about this
without revealing him okay he is from
philadelphia i had there's a couple of
his songs that i listened to
he hit me up on raya he went like he
direct
messaged me he like paid extra or
whatever is that how it works you pay
extra
or you like get i don't know i have no
clue how it works i
i was only on raya a little bit before i
got snatched up
um so he direct messaged me and then it
was like very good
conversation because he's from philly so
we're talking about philly some from
philly
and um and we found out we were both
quake brought up quaker
which is like a whole thing i mean it's
like a very
small portion of the world it's quaker
so it was really cool
so we're reviving we're both quakers so
then when he came into town we went to
quaker meeting together we had our date
was we went to our church together
which was pretty fun it was like it's
kind of a boring situation but it was
fun we had this whole like long fun date
and
he's like a really weird exception
except eccentric
he's an odd odd man but i liked him i
thought it was cool
and uh you know i'm always down to bang
someone visiting town uh
if you're gonna leave i'll probably have
sex with you
this was old annie okay and
um we just only hung out once we never
run out again
but he did like to keep he kept he would
always text me like i left my sunglasses
stuff like that i'm like they cost 10
cents like do you want to hang out with
me again or not
he's like i can't wait to see you again
i'm like okay
and then he just never it was a lot of
like breadcrumbing and weird stuff but
he was like i i have like okay vibes
from him i don't know i have no respect
for that when
someone is like a guy to like
when i went up to one of my girlfriends
is like like that term you just use
breadcrumbing i don't i don't know
exactly what it is but well they just
like drop little things dangling the
carrots
that's what you're interested in yeah
why that's so he was
actually yeah you know what i i do have
fond i i think
fondly of him because he's very weird
but it was [ __ ] the way he treated
me because it was like
you're in or you're out he was so like
like texting me all the time it would be
like texting like all day right and then
it would go like two weeks he wouldn't
text me and then i'm like
okay whatever then he will come back and
it'll be like text text text and then so
when we did hang out and it was really
fun we had like a really fun time
and i know he was recording his album so
he's busy but i'm a comedian i'm an
artist too i'm always busy i was
performing every single night i was
that was when uh spade show was on i was
like filming stuff during the day
i hit him up like a couple days later or
later that week and was like hey i'm
like doing this thing if you want to
come and he was like
that's too far and i'm like oh you said
you wanted to come
it was just like everything was like i
would he said things to me and then i
would follow what he said
and then he would be like kind of mad at
me
like i was like whoa when do you want to
hang out he's like i'm busy working and
i'm like
you said you want to hang out with me
yeah i accidentally like i
butt faced timed him yeah like a month
later which is pretty embarrassing but
at this point
yeah who gives a [ __ ] so and he didn't
pick up and then like
two weeks later he texted me and he was
like oh hey i was on tour in mexico
like trying to brag or something i'm
like my job's cooler than yours
and like um i saw you facetime what's up
and i just never responded but sometimes
i go on his instagram we don't follow
each other but sometimes i go on his
instagram and i leave little like
neggy mean comments what do you say he
had some line that was something about
like
don't pick up birds or something and
they was wearing a hat with all these
feathers in it and i was like well why
would you put it in your hat then like i
just
like kind of like little like why do you
do that
just a little memory i do love that
about you sometimes i'll tell annie
about a person i know
or an acquaintance and she's and
immediately she within two seconds she's
in their instagram like commenting on
like a picture of like
lobster hey do you guys have any more
for me for like six months ago
from six months ago i follow her still
she got a good lobster the other day oh
she did a big man
so i'll tell her about a friend who like
you know dives for lobster and within
three seconds she's there
i like collecting cool people i would
have followed him i would have stayed
friends with him and everything but he
um he didn't follow me so i was like i'm
not gonna follow you but
you know sometimes when guys or whoever
they like one time i was dating a guy
and he like
it was a very rough not like perfect
relationship like i think we'd already
broken up got back together whatever and
then like one day
he like i went over to his place
wherever he was staying
and he like put like flowers out and
made me dinner and drew me a bath and
like made this look
really nice i hate to tell you it's
because your [ __ ] smells like
you give me badges though no but i have
dated guys to scrape my tongue before
kissing me
and i was like this is so weird it's so
out of character like why is he doing
all this nice stuff for me and then i
realized like that was a life lesson for
me i was like 22 and i was like oh
sometimes people do this stuff for
themselves like he's like performing for
himself
like putting on like the nice thing and
that's sometimes what they do and it
really
tricks you because if you don't if you
don't connect those dots you're like
oh my god he's he's in love with me yeah
i'm his queen
the same thing kind of [ __ ] me up very
early on in life and i had to kind of
unlearn this part
i used to think that when people when
guys did nice things for me it was a
compensation for something they were
doing behind my back
because um one of the guys that i was so
in love with that
absolutely shattered me the weekend that
he came
home after like banging a whole lot of
other people which was hard to do when
he had all those kids
indian man remember but he um
he came home and he was like hey he's
like let's buy a motorcycle
and at this point this is like my motor
i own a motorcycle by the way for years
um did you ever write it not one that he
yeah i did
a harley not one that he um bought me
but this is one of my you know my
wannabe cool girl phase
did you ever my whale tail of course
and so um let's buy a motorcycle and i'm
like yeah i mean it's weird but yeah
okay let's go and he we went we had a
best day at the harley store
we were like going around with like the
euros that they had like really cool day
and the next day he's like we should buy
a time share together i'm gonna buy you
a time share
and so he bought a timeshare and he was
like we could go some timeshares were
still a thing
and then like the third day is when i
was like something's up like something's
really fishy
and what was fishy was my vagina because
it was burning and i realized why
there's only one reason why my vagina
could be on in flames like this
and sure enough i had caught an std i
thought this was going to just be
casually coming out with herpes i was
like wow good for you
but then not yet anytime someone does
like really
big acts of like really like grandiose
stuff like that for me i get very
defensive i'm like what
what's happening what did you do it is
like love bombing though right it's like
a narcissistic thing because think about
like this person too
is like he's um a successful artist
he's like used to being like on stage in
front of people and like i understand
that sort of ego too obviously
from what i do but you do think about
like i don't know i guess
i just wasn't that i mean i was
impressed i think it's cool that he's an
artist and that he's you know he's a
talented guy and stuff but it's not like
i mean some of the [ __ ] lyrics i was
like it's not like i'm like
flicking my bean over here to his albums
you know what i mean
but it's not like i didn't come reach
out to you [ __ ] like you came to me but
it is like
i i could imagine him being like damn
i'm really like [ __ ] killing it on
this date i have a confession
what that song his song was one of my
myspace songs
for a couple months oh my god do you
want me to set you guys up maybe he's
your guy
oh god she's what she's doing
i would never yeah but who's really with
bobby
we we use this house
if he leaves again we need to get bobby
to propose to her
somehow if he leaves me annie this is
all over
our careers are over we can't use this
garage anymore
um bryce what do you have prepared for
us today
oh my god what is bryce
this is dangit i love this stuff
what is it it's a dried fish oh no
i grew up on this [ __ ] it's the best no
i still
scrape your tongue my family business
might not my family business my uncle's
business was making these was drying up
like when you go to your uncle's house
they were just like dried fish
are you gonna eat it annie of course
when am i not it's actually very good
do you think that's better worse than
this definitely not
no what is that the camera what is it
ew why is my baby food they should go to
esther
no no no this is baby food
this is for esther annie don't worry
you're gonna eat what i'm holding this
is
absolutely not i know what it is i've
seen these at kids parties when i used
to babysit
it's [ __ ] crazy is that because you
weren't you weren't invited
when you were a kid
what happened take it off my lap
take it off my lap who dude who is in
trouble
why did you bring me these what is it
dude it's [ __ ]
full on crickets oh my god
dude dude i'll get it i'll get it i'll
get it
get it i'll get i'll say the crickets
you're screaming like they're alive
dude oh my god don't look i cannot look
at them they're huge
whole crickets honestly what's in the
skirt is scarier to me
dude why what is this just regular baby
food or is it like
yeah you got flavored give her those
crickets those are for her this
bryce made a mistake oh my god if this
had like
flown up and all of them flung on esther
what a happy accent though can i just
say
i don't want any kind of jokes like no
one's done anything to you
pranks like i would love to just see you
try the fish and then i want to i do
want to see you eat the crickets though
do you see i just want to see this is
we've summed it up where'd you get these
are these fresh
all right so i do want to say it has an
aroma of oh day
s a stem it does not hold a day five day
old
this is this i would be driving you a
bath too i can eat a lot of pineapple
okay okay these are crickets all right
look at it
these are salt and vinegar are you going
to eat it kalaelis yeah i'm going to try
it i don't like that it doesn't just
break it's not my first cricket okay it
is kind of gross it does
i feel like you know what they're
usually supposed to be a lot crunchy or
annie
but it's very tasty maybe hot sauce
yeah it's it's they're not as fresh as i
wanted them to be but if you had real
good like blood
with rice oh my gosh i think i could
really wait with rice and what
like fried fish and stuff well dried
fish with a little bit of vinegar in it
the best here i could see us like
watching tv
and me just really getting into it would
you like a cricket madam
yeah oh rest in peace
sorry that your life was taken for
snacks
are you [ __ ] kidding me i don't know
i don't even eat my bryce you know i'm
vegetarian
have you ever killed her i've eaten
crickets before yeah
but i haven't had these particular ones
now annie you're really like okay with
this
yes you're ready in one two
three oh delicious mmm
apps it's it's delicious esther peanutty
nothing crickety about it at all
peanutty i actually like the fish better
though
but there's no taste even it's just like
a chip
i'm sorry mr cricket should we move on
to i see marshmallows do we have more
treats this week are we trying an esther
delicate delicacy
i is is that what it is i mean esther's
delicacy is
such a joke yeah esther will make it for
us she is weird about this by the way
there's nothing weird it's just called
dry s'mores thank you so much
and a lot of people what they like to do
is they sit by a campfire they melt
their
marshmallows and their chocolate and
they like a gushy mushy s'mores
but i'm telling you dry raw
s'mores just all non-cooked is
delicious you trying to claim s'mores as
your own
is wild right now so and i want you guys
to tell me
or you think if you think like oh no of
course we should roast this instead or
if you kind of like it dry
well i'm i'm kind of i have an aversion
to things that might stab
the roof of my mouth and oh that seems
terrible feeling yeah you know when you
eat chips and these oh you take a chip
the wrong direction
wrong direction slices you down the
whole way
what are your expectations um i feel
like i think it's gonna taste exactly
like i know it's gonna taste because
we've all
had s'mores before sometimes they're not
they're not really like that high you
know
here we go
hmm it's so messy after
no i mean it's good all the ingredients
are delicious
i just don't like it i would like it a
little like melty though
i love it this way i think it's so much
better this way the chocolate does taste
better this way
i love it this way but the going from
the fish
to cricket to this made it all the more
delicious
i have to say i want to say i had a
little appetizer
that you didn't have well you guys thank
you for listening to this week's
bloodbath
um that was so much sure it's a mukbang
um this show is turning into a
full-blown mukbang every week
we appreciate you please go to itunes
and give us five stars
six stars seven stars all the stars we
love you and we'll see you next week
[Music]
you